this is why jd can't breathe on a hike
when he goes with john blind on it oh i
could breathe on a hike i was breathing
fine these guys had a 23 course japanese
dinner oh
jd ate half the sea of japan
yeah i noticed jd when he's eating uh
starts complaining about he doesn't want
spicy food and even the food he
complains about doesn't seem all that
spicy i feel like he probably needs a
dental appointment because everything's
irritating his mouth nothing too spicy
or anything oh
a little cake if we need a fire
extinguisher in my mouth oh my gosh why
i just i'm not a spicy food guy i don't
know what to tell you i can give jd a
dental checkup get in there no the best
was there was a ceramic plate with a
pattern on it
and jd thought it was like a sauce on
the plate i know this is like you
wipe it into the stuffing jd thought
this was a sauce yeah it was a design on
the plate that i thought you know you
know these fancy places they put like
little designs on the plate with like a
with a sauce or whatever and i thought
but that was really a design on the
plate
it's like taking a three-year-old oh
well also i gotta note that jd thought
wasabi was edamame and kept getting
confused jd was waxing poetically about
edamame and how you kind of like it he
was like going on and on and the sushi
chef was like uh it's uh wasabi and
everyone around him started laughing
that he was confusing the two things i
learned something about the trip that i
didn't know and i don't know how you
left this out of your report john the
night that jd went to natalie maine's
house he fell asleep at natalie's house
yeah
i knocked it off i nodded off for a
second
every second
how did that happen john so we're
sitting in her living room we're all
chatting and natalie's like john john
just look look and jd's just
complete dreamland
oh yes well no i not for like a second
and then i look up and i see everyone
staring at me oh no they were getting an
original jd moment and so everybody had
to stop and observe
you know
he was snoring away it was just like it
was like sleeping with a bear it's a
once in a lifetime experience but don't
you think it's because he's like gorging
on uh fast foods and and
and drinking
drugs edibles and drinking animals yes i
always tell them i'm like jd this is 20
milligrams take half and he takes the
whole thing oh no you're now you're full
of no
you're acting like an [ __ ] it is 100
i would not take anything 20 milligrams
yeah you did
i wouldn't lie i wouldn't lie to howard
and robin it's just not my thing oh yeah
okay all right i know you're the
ultimate prankster and everything but
how do you not carry a little one of
those uh air horns with you for when jd
falls asleep to wake up next next time
yeah no i will then that's gonna happen
i hate those air horns i'm not that's
not happening see that even makes it
better no yeah
[Music]
you